Germans emigrating to the United States in the mid-19th century...
...had to leave out of the port of Hamburg...
...and would sometimes have to wait months for passage.
It would have been at this point that they developed the fondness for a local dish...
...called the Hamburg steak,...
...which was chopped, cooked beef, served on a plate with potatoes and gravy.
Upon arriving in New York City, the Germans found that their familiar food...
...also made its way to America, and was already hugely popular,...
...from high-end restaurants like Delmonico's to food carts all over Lower Manhattan.
News of the Hamburg steak spread, and soon it was available all across America.
Now, things get interesting.
It took another 20 to 30 years for the Hamburg steak...
...to be served between two slices of bread.
From that point on, a patty between two buns became recognized around the world...
...as a distinctly American dish called the hamburger.